[AUDIO LOGO]
- Happy Thursday, everybody. Welcome
back to the Data Science
Hangout. If it's your
first time joining us here
today, it's so nice to
meet you. I'm Rachael.
Thanks for spending your
Thursday with all of us.
And so the hangout is our
open space to chat about data
science leadership,
questions you're facing,
and getting to hear what's
going on in the world of data
across different industries.
So if this is your
first time here,
we are here every Thursday at
the same time, the same place.
And if you're watching
this recording on YouTube later,
you can also add it to your
calendar if you want to join us
virtually here on Zoom as well.
Curtis,
I'm going to make sure that I
made you a co-host so you can
help me with the waiting room,
as people are coming in here.
OK, awesome.
CURTIS: Yeah, you bet.
- Together,
we're all dedicated to
making this a welcoming environment
for everybody. So we love
to hear from everyone, no matter
your years of
experience, titles, industry,
or languages even
that you work in.
So every week at the hangout,
I'm joined by a different
leader from the community who
joins us to share their experience
and answer questions from you all.
So it is totally OK to
just listen in if you want,
but there's also three ways you
can jump in and ask questions
or provide your own
perspective on certain topics.
So you can raise
your hand on Zoom,
and I'll be sure to be
on the lookout here.
You can put questions
in the Zoom chat.
And put a little star next
to it if it's something you want
me to read out loud instead,
or else I'll just call on you
to jump in here and join the party.
But third,
we also have a Slido link
where you can ask questions
anonymously.
And I see Hannah just shared that
right as I said it. So thank you.
But I'm so excited to be joined
by my co-host today, Andey
Nunes-Brewster. Andey is an EMS
and trauma research analyst at
Oregon Health
Authority. And Andey,
I'd love to have you
jump in here and introduce yourself,
share a little bit about
your role and also something you
like to do outside of work too.
- Sure, OK. So
I've been with the Oregon
Health Authority since January
of 2020 in this role.
I work with a team that
coordinates the emergency medical services
throughout the state of Oregon.
And so our program
licenses health care professionals who
are first responders,
including EMTs and paramedics
of all kinds, all shades.
And we also regulate
ambulance services.
We
have a data system for
electronic patient
care records for
field responses, so ambulance
calls that do patient care
or transport a patient.
Every one of those patient
records is in a repository that
we get. That data comes
in practically real time.
We have all those within
48 hours of an event.
And then we also have several
time-sensitive emergency
registries that we
manage, including trauma,
and cardiac arrest, and stroke.
Some of those have
integrations with the EMS data.
And one of the things I'm really
excited about getting to work on is
a project with the Oregon
Department of Transportation,
where we're looking at the
feasibility of interoperability
between the various EMS data sets
that we have and crash data.
And so that--
that's really exciting too.
And then outside of work,
I do play a couple of
musical instruments from time to time.
That's a topic that comes
up often in this space.
And I have a couple of kids,
one of whom is about to
move into a dorm at the University
of Oregon in Eugene. And we
just got to take him there for
a couple of orientation sessions.
And I'm excited about that.
He's sort of interested in
data science, which I'm,
you know, crossing my
fingers, but also like,
go have fun and
have an adventure.
And then I also
have a two-year-old,
or soon to be two-year-old. So
it's daycare and college
at the same time for me. So
I'm happy to have a
permanent government position
at this time so.
- You are busy.
- I'm very busy, yes. Thanks.
- Well, thank you so much,
Andey, for joining us.
I was thinking back to when we
first got to chat one on one.
And I think it was because
you were building up your own
community internally when we first
got to chat one on one.
So I'd love to learn more
about that experience and
what led you to start
an internal group,
as we're waiting for questions
to come in from everybody here.
- Yeah, so--
and I'm
correcting a couple of
acronyms. If folks--
if I start peppering
the acronyms,
I'll try to throw those
in the chat too. So yeah,
our community group
really arose out of
a couple of sections
got together,
the Injury and Violence
Prevention section and the EMS
folks in my program.
And we wanted to
do some training in R,
relating to kind of upskilling the
team to be able to collaborate.
And--
and really,
we were working on a
procurement for Posit for
enterprise solutions so
that we can use Connect
and do more with the
data that we have.
And so
out of this training,
we ended up creating a
Teams group. So our whole organization,
our primary way of
communicating with each other
is email through Outlook
and then chat through Teams.
And we have lots of
channels that support various working groups.
And so there was a Team channel
that was created for that
RStudio Academy cohort.
And
after the 10 weeks
of us together,
we all felt like we just wanted
to share everything we had
learned with everyone else. And so
we opened up the group to
everybody. And
the first week, we had--
there was--
so there was eight
of us to start with.
We had about six people join
in that first week when we
finished and said,
let's just invite everyone and
let's share what we've learned.
The next month, there was
about 40 people in that group.
And by the second month, we had over
100 people in that group. And that was--
and that's only word of mouth.
There isn't anyone running
the group right now.
We have--
it's all sort of like,
we just get together and
what do people want? What
do people need? What can folks
bring? Who can we find
to help bring that?
And so it's fairly organic.
And we're doing a little
bit of work now to try to
make it a little more formal,
but it's still very
much a work in progress.
- That's great. So it all
started with those people who were--
- The Academy.
- [INAUDIBLE]
together?
- Yeah,
the academy cohort.
-
I figured it probably would
be helpful for anybody who hasn't
heard of what Academy is
to just explain what that process
was the team went through too.
- Sure.
So we
learned about it
through the website,
and then got in touch with
the folks at Posit, and
learned that it's 10 weeks,
where we get a--
where our group is assigned
a mentor and we get
some health care
data to work with.
And we go through
some tutorial modules.
Some of this is asynchronous,
some of this we could
choose to work together.
It was really up to the
group how to manage getting through
the tutorial materials.
And then we would do
an exercise each week
where you reproduce
something, right,
either a table,
or a way to clean the
data and arrange it, or a visualization,
and then from there, build
on it on your own, right, do
something to expand upon
that topic that week.
And so our group really
got a couple of things
out of that experience, sort of
drops the barriers and some
of the initial hesitation about
sharing code with one
another. And we learn how to
support each other in
improving code and how to--
it's not just about speaking,
you know, kindly
or sandwiching your
critique with some
positive things.
Like, it's more than that.
It's about understanding where each
other is in the learning
process and really helping
each other achieve our goals.
And so there's a lot of
learning how to listen to each
other too. So that was really--
I felt that was really--
a really great thing
to come away with.
- That's awesome. I bet
there's something to
learn from that experience too,
like you had this close knit
group of people who were
already working together who
helped build this community.
And that's probably helped
to make it successful too.
I see--
oh, sorry. You go ahead, Andey.
- No, I was just going to
say and one of the references that
I've been using personally
in just sort of guiding
my role in this is a book by,
let's see, it's Josh Bacon or--
I could grab it real quick.
It's called The
Art of
Community. And
the author is
someone from the Linux community.
And so a lot of the content
from this book and the approach
from this book has been kind
of folded into the Linux Foundation
culture.
And so anything that I've
ever done that touches Linux
Foundation work
has just felt so
intentionally inclusive and
just oriented in a way that
I feel really strongly to want to
align with it. And
so I've been doing a little
work on my own to try to
steer my participation
in that direction anyway.
- That's great. Thank you.
I'm going to jump over to
some of the questions here in the
chat. And I love to
see the conversation happening too.
Ted, I think you had
a question about the group.
- Yeah. I mean, well, Andey and
I know each other. So hey, Andey.
- Hi, Ted.
-
So one of the things that
I've heard a lot with starting these
groups is people really
want to participate,
but they're so busy.
So
I found that one of the routes to
kind of improving that is to get sponsors
among leadership. Do you have
any experience with that?
- No. That's a really
interesting idea.
And I'm curious about what the
role of the sponsor really would be.
Because I would want to be
able to articulate that to--
in I'm in my head it
sounds kind of like, mentoring, like,
someone who's in a leadership
position that can say,
go ahead and participate
because we're getting this
value back out of it, or
something along those lines.
And then folks feel like they have
the space to ask for that, right?
- Yeah. I think--
I think just someone who can
formally say that for an entire
group, that it's OK
to spend time on this.
I think also it's just people--
like, people who are willing--
like,
if your supervisor is willing for
you to dedicate time to it,
to organizing,
things like that.
- Yeah.
I mean, right now,
one of the things we're working
on is getting leadership.
And when I say leadership,
I mean the Oregon Health
Authority Director's Office.
Like, our overall arch
agency leadership is getting
some support there. We've got
a couple of advocates right now.
But when I mean
formalizing the support,
like having something where
someone's got a project they're
working on and they're
spending time supporting this community.
And so that's
coming from not just our
folks in public health,
but that's coming from
all over the agency.
So
I think we're heading
in that direction.
But the idea of sponsors sounds
really interesting to me.
It's also similar to
where it kind of--
I guess it has a different
level of where in the
power hierarchy that
it's using. But also like the
idea of having sort of like a
mentor network, right,
where I know of a few folks
who are working on some things that
I'm trying to learn,
and also I can share back
with folks who are trying to learn
some of the things
that I'm working on.
And we've talked about maybe
ways to do something like that
with the group as well.
Really,
it's about fostering
connections and creating a
culture of inclusivity, where
everyone can do data science.
Anyone here who's working
with data, whether that's language,
and surveys, and qualitative
information, or it's our
quantitative EPI stuff,
that everyone is welcome.
Everyone is here to learn.
We're here to support each other.
- Few other questions
coming in on,
like, this learning
process for your team.
And I see Ben asked
a question about--
around Git. Ben, do you
want to jump in here?
- Yeah. We--
there's a lot of interest
in R, but then there's this,
obviously, backbone of
[INAUDIBLE], which is Git,
which I'm struggling
introducing to them because a
lot of the analysts and
data scientists, they're not, quote unquote,
"engineers." So just curious
if you addressed that hurdle,
if you've seen it, and if
the process you went through helped.
- Right, so
there's a couple of things
happening with our access to
Git right now. Sorry,
I just bumped my chair.
And
we have limited access to it
at this point. There's ongoing
conversations between
IT, and data engineers,
and the informatics
side of the house, where--
informatics is
convincing and showing the
business case that we need to
be able to do DevOps
that's not been understood by
IT in the past. And
so we're
trying to get access to Git.
And right now, we can use Azure
DevOps, but not many of us are.
Most of us are more
familiar with GitHub.
So most of that learning is
really focused out of all of
us, as state employees,
have access to a resource
at the State of Oregon Library.
It's a library that's part
of the state government. And it's--
so it provides resources
to state agencies.
And one of our resources is
the O'Reilly learning platform.
And so we can go on to
O'Reilly and take any of those
asynchronous courses
and live courses. And
we're supported in
learning through that
resource as well.
And I've taken a handful of--
like, Brent Lassiter, I think,
does some Git courses through
O'Reilly that have been really
helpful, like just
learning command line Git.
But you know, it's--
even the part where we're
convincing folks to, you know,
you do want to spend this
kind of time learning R,
we have to also have the
discussion about how learning
is part of your productivity,
right? And that if
we're not learning, we're actually--
we're actually
losing ground on building
capacity for our future work
because we're not going to
ever have less work to do,
right?
And so
a lot of what we're doing is
trying to find ways to be more
efficient with the
work that we do.
But as soon as we're doing-- you
know, we save--
oh, I automated this
report and I saved myself
10 hours every quarter
from rerunning this report. Well,
those 10 hours are--
like, as soon as you
say that like that,
that time is going to
another project that also really needs
to get done right. So--
so we do have to say,
well, even though you have that pressure,
your learning is part
of the productivity.
And so there's time that--
that time that you're
spending there isn't just--
there's--
meeting your learning
objectives as part of what
we're here to do.
And it's just as much part
of your outcome, right, or output.
Any other questions on the
learning I could pivot to
another one of these
questions about the data or?
- Yeah,
I'll handle the questions.
I have the Posit team in
the background helping me.
ANDEY-NUNES
BREWSTER: OK, thanks.
- But I see, Alan, you
had asked a question around the
data landscape. Do you
want to jump in here?
- Yeah, sure. Hi, Andey.
ANDEY-NUNES BREWSTER: Hi.
- So like, big picture,
I'm super fascinated at how--
like, I conceive of emergency services
as being, like, this whole other
ring of service providers
in the medical landscape.
And I'm curious how they
interact with you as an agency.
And then tactically,
how does how does their data
come into your landscape?
And then--
and I know I'm sort
of rolling on and on,
but I'm really curious, like,
what kinds of problems are
you solving with that data?
Is it about like,
resource allocation? Is it about--
is it about where people
are in terms of location,
like distribution of services
and that kind of stuff?
I realize there's
a bunch there.
Whatever is kind of interesting in
there that you want to speak
to I'd love to hear about.
- Yeah, so--
so
our program is the
regulatory body. We're the regulators.
ALAN: OK.
-
Folks that provide these
services are licensed through
our office. And
there are standards of care
in place for providing those
services. And we collect the data
for that to be able to do
quality improvement and
to do compliance work.
So we do compliance for
ambulance services.
And part of that is
reviewing your records--
and are you completing your
patient care records? Are you
appropriately checking the
right boxes for particular
cases? So there's--
And then we also do that for
trauma hospitals as well.
So certified trauma centers, that
data is used to verify
aspects of the patient care
itself and also verify aspects
of their performance
improvement because all
trauma hospitals are required
to have an ongoing performance
improvement program.
So--
so essentially, the data is
used for compliance and safety,
but it is also used for--
in the field, it can be
used for decision making in
patient care.
So one of the problems
that we've tackled recently is
documentation of weight for
patients who receive a
weight-based medication in the
field. And so this
is especially important in pediatrics.
And
our program was able to collect
data to see when there's a
weight-based medication that
is administered in the field,
how often is the
weight documented in the record.
We developed a performance
metric out of this.
And we did a letter
writing campaign to our ambulance
agencies. And now,
our expectation was that this
would be a pretty conventional
thing. We'd see a 20%
response rate or something super low.
But it was off--
it was off the chart.
We went from
somewhere in the, you know,
below our threshold to almost 100%
within a couple of months
of implementing of that letter
writing campaign and sharing
back with everyone their
performance metric and where they
were compared to where we
are as the state.
And we're now doing multiple
performance metrics.
And so we do them for
both EMS and trauma.
A lot of that is
on our website.
So
I hope I touched
on some of that.
In terms of how the
data gets to us,
we actually manage--
we have third-party vendors who
provide
electronic patient
care record software.
And we have--
so we have a vendor
who provides a software for our
electronic medical
record systems and--
and then also for our
licensing management system and then also
for the trauma registry.
And the folks that do the
EMS system also provide our
stroke and care registry
integrations as well.
And so we do a lot of vendor
management and a lot of
user support between
our users and
things that we can
do with the vendor,
but things we also have to ask
the vendor to do for us, you know?
- Awesome, thank you. Yeah,
that touched on, like,
a whole bunch of stuff
I'm interested in.
It sounds like it's a neat
landscape of complex systems.
And then your ability to
pull performance things out of that
data and address it directly
I think is really cool.
It's super neat to
think about. Thanks.
- Yeah, and R is really
crucial to that whole workflow. Because
without it--
we're using the vendor's tools
to assess how those software
are performing, but that's
not always even possible.
And so having a way to
pull data from one table,
look at where things are
moving into a submissions table from
the other side, look at what
was received on the other side--
since joining this team,
I'm learning XML, and HL7,
and some of these other ways
of moving data between systems that--
it's definitely not where
I thought I was headed,
but it's super-exciting.
[CHORTLES]
-
I want to make sure I jump
over to some of the Slido questions too.
So just to remind everybody if
you joined a little bit later,
you can also ask questions
anonymously on Slido.
But one of the--
and Hannah will share that
in the chat. But one of the
questions there was,
what kinds of governance or
policies do you have for using
R across your agency?
So for example,
deployment guidelines,
or software upgrade
policies, approved packages.
- Yeah, that is really
loosely defined at the moment.
At the moment, it's--
R is only supported at the--
at the individual desktop level.
And you have to go
through an exceptions process
to be able to download it.
And then everyone is on their
own for managing their own
package libraries.
It's pretty
in incongruous in terms
of being able to collaborate.
You have to do a lot of
your own lift to ensure
that everyone can open and
run the same projects if that's
what you're trying to do.
And so we're really trying
to work towards having a--
an enterprise-supported
solution.
And that's been a long haul.
There's a lot of grant money
that's going in to support it,
but there's also bureaucracy
and transparency that
we are in that--
we just have processes we
have to go through. And so
it takes longer than we
think it should sometimes.
But
we're spending taxpayer money.
And we also have grant--
grantees--
you know, grant funders that we
have to report back to. And so
yeah, just trying to figure out
how to do that. But right now,
it's not very coordinated.
- I don't know how I'm
about to ask this question.
I haven't formulated it in my
head, so it might come out weird.
- Sure, OK.
- But
I feel like you were very
creative with getting around
some of that to at least
push things forward with being able
to train new users and bring
together this community.
And I think it's worth talking
about that too, like, you maybe
hit roadblocks in one way,
but went in a different direction.
- Yeah, I mean--
so I guess it's a matter of
I guess accepting the things
that we can control and
focusing on the areas
where we have some agency.
And so
if we're told you can't use
that tool right now, you have
to go through this process of
approval that is 12 steps deep,
and 14 different programs are
going to touch that [INAUDIBLE]
process--
I'm kind of exaggerating
here. But it's a lot, and--
and for
a lot of really good reasons,
a lot of legal reasons too.
And
at each one of these
roadblocks, we just say, OK,
so we're not able to move
forward with this in this way
now.
We're going to try to
keep moving in this direction.
What can we do with the
resources and the time that we have.
And then we brainstorm a little bit
and see what ideas are in the room
and then just kind
of go from there.
So a lot of this isn't
me doing it. I'm just asking questions.
And then I'm doing what I
can to support folks and us
following up and
supporting each other.
Thank you.
-
And I see some of my colleagues
are in here popping some
comments in the chat too.
So I love that some folks have
been able to join and share as
well. Because really, I
did want to bring more of
the group experience here and not
just my own thing.
I might share a couple of
shiny app links for some injury data
just to give these folks some
kudos. Because the learning
with them has been really
awesome. And I'm really proud
of the work we're doing together.
- Absolutely. If you want
to call anybody up here.
[INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHTER]
I see, Abigail, you had
a question a bit earlier
regarding the training piece.
Do you want to ask that?
- Yeah. So I've worked
with the government too.
And I would never
suggest, like,
don't train people because
they'll leave. Like, that's terrible.
But how do you--
but how do you think
about the attrition piece
when you're training people in
some skills that will make them
able, you know, more able
to leave, possibly for more money?
How do you think about
supporting them and what you
can do to keep them
after they're trained up?
- That's a really good
question. And I'm not a
manager. So I don't really know
what they do
to keep people
engaged
even without the learning,
right? Just the fact that
we're doing this work,
it pays more in
the private sector,
like, it just does.
Especially for folks who want
to live in Portland, like,
where Portland has a higher--
there's areas in this state
that have a much higher cost of
living than other areas in the
state. And for a lot of us,
we're working remotely.
And so there was--
you know,
a lot of folks decided to
move to smaller towns because the
cost of living
and inflation just
really kind of took
a lot of progress
from folks in public--
in public sector pay
in the last couple of years. So
I don't really have a
good answer for that.
The only thing I will say is
in terms of what we can do for
each other on a team
is that--
is creating the culture that
keeps people engaged and that
makes people feel like
they're a part of something
larger, right, and
feeling connected.
One of the things
we hear a lot from
folks in this group is,
I feel like I'm the only
one on my team using R. And
100 people after two months
just is showing us that that's
not really
necessarily the case,
that there are other people
potentially using it or even
wanting to learn,
and we're just not able
to connect with one another.
And so I think
having these communities is one of these
ways that we can start to engage folks.
But also,
I'm not sure that
there's a really
easy answer for that. Because
of course, folks are willing to--
we have agency to work
for whomever we want to.
And public sector just has to--
I don't know.
I think nonprofits
have a similar--
a similar challenge in that you
want to support your people to
learn and grow and you
want to keep them. And
sometimes that means we have
to pay them what they think
they're worth. So like,
that's just a challenge
of how to make that fit.
Yeah, it's not a
good answer, but--
ABIGAIL: No. I
mean, it's right.
Yeah. No, it's hard. It's
something we really struggled with
like soft brokers too. So
it's tough to keep people.
Cybersecurity, that's a
big one. They just leave.
- Yeah, yeah.
So I don't know, maybe
we start training people knowing that--
that if we're only
supporting them in
growing in skills and not
supporting in everything else,
that that's just
what's going to happen.
And then you got to plan
for that. I don't know.
I mean,
part of what keeps me
here is that our organization really
does focus on racial justice.
We do focus on equity work.
We do focus on these other
pieces that make me feel like
I'm contributing to the
community in a way that's
beyond just improving our
health care system.
And that's part of
what keeps me here.
- Is the quote like, what if
I train them and they leave?
But what if you
don't and they stay?
- Yeah, right? RACHAEL
DEMPSEY: Yeah.
- [CHUCKLES]
- Let's jump over to--
one other question from Slido
was, Oregon is known for great
community responder programs. How
does this impact your work?
- Yeah, I think that there's
a lot going on in Oregon with
expanding community
paramedicine and
having
support for behavioral
health crises that isn't--
you know, the first
person responding is
a behavioral health
specialist and not a medical
provider, right?
So there's some--
and
there--
sorry,
I'm a little distracted by some of
the fun comments going on in the chat.
- It is really hard to
not want to [INAUDIBLE].
- No, it's fun.
No, it's totally--
it's all fun. Please don't-- RACHAEL
DEMPSEY: I love
the chat comments.
- Please keep it coming.
Yeah, and so like,
as regulators, we
kind of have to
be--
we have to be really clear with
here's the line at which if
you're doing patient care,
you have to have patient
care record systems.
These are the rules, right?
We have to be really clear
with what the rules are.
And then if
you're not
providing those services, then
there's certainly
ways in which our--
our
advisory groups are
involved in those
other groups. So like,
mountain rescue has a person
who sits on our EMS state
committee, for example. So
they're not necessarily an
ambulance transporting agency,
but they're certainly involved in
a lot of different types of
events.
And so--
so those folks get involved in
our community groups.
We have several.
We have regional
trauma advisory boards.
We have a state trauma advisory
board and a state EMS advisory
board. We have a couple of
data working groups that we run with
folks that are kind of
our data super users
in both EMS and trauma.
And so
really, in terms of
community involvement,
we're more of providing
information and helping connect resources
and not doing a
whole lot of the--
like,
the community's doing the
work and then coming to us and
saying, hey, we're seeing
this. What can we do?
And we try to put together
some resources and work with them.
- Thank you.
I see, Jared,
you had a question a
bit earlier about working with
HIPAA data. Do you
want to jump in here?
JARED: Hi, Andey.
Sorry. Yeah, I
think, for me, it's--
like, you speak on so
many things that I've
dealt with. But how
do you manage to--
like, on a public health
level, do you talk with other
states or even at a
national level to like,
collaborate on future--
kind of future initiatives
or future endeavors, where
those--
you know, when I
was in my role,
like HIPAA was not as much of
a concern with a lot of the data
we were collating and
kept bringing together.
But I feel like in your role,
it's got to be a lot more--
an important kind of staple
that may prevent collaboration from happening.
So I just didn't know if you
could kind of speak on how that
all has kind of come into
your fold and how you've managed it.
- Yeah. So for the
most part, our vendors
are required to be compliant
under a handful of things.
HIPAA is just one
of them, right?
And there's other cybersecurity things that
they have to be compliant with.
And so--
so we're
very much--
like, it's very much part of
our data governance, right, is that
all of our systems
are compliant with those
requirements. It definitely also
comes into play with our
fulfilling data requests.
But it's--
at this point, it's not so much
an obstacle as just part of the
framework that we're
operating under.
And so
we
have to use secure
tools for doing any data
sharing when we're doing our
compliance work with hospitals, for
example, right? And so that's--
I have a cybersecurity team that
I call them and say, hey,
this is what we're
doing. Are we good?
And there's--
so it's a huge team effort.
The HIPAA stuff is
really just part--
is just part of
our data governance. It's just--
yeah, it
just seems like it's part of
whatever we're doing. And
I don't really have to worry
about that so as much as
I've just got the rules, the
rules that I follow, and that's
how we operate.
It's probably not a really
great question for that but--
or answer. Sorry, not a great
answer for your question, but the--
JARED: No, it makes sense.
I think it's just about knowing--
like,
you brought up that you
have kind of a cybersecurity
department that allows you to
be your
conscience when it comes to
sharing data and doing things
like that. Because
it was more of--
like, in my role,
it was more like,
if you don't feel comfortable then
don't do it. But how do
you manage that to a degree
when you're trying to work across
multiple public health
organizations to try and find
some level of consistency or
standardization to how you're doing things?
And so then that became a
bigger conversation,
a bigger problem.
So I just was kind of
curious how Oregon-- I
never got that far--
that far to the
coast. But I was like,
I wonder how big
this could be made?
I know there's some governance
at the national level.
But could this be an
OK thing of like, hey,
if you're having a lot
of issues in Oregon, maybe
Washington, or maybe
California's having similar things?
And you guys can talk
and collaborate to come up with
answers, if that makes sense.
- Yeah, and we
certainly do that.
So there are national
standards for EMS data.
I dropped a link in the
chat for the NEMSIS,
the organization that
handles all that.
There's also national
data standards for trauma.
And
definitely, like,
one of the things that I
feel like I'm really good at is,
like, I get to a situation
where I'm like, hmm,
this is something I
haven't done before.
And I have a sense of
what I'm going to do,
but I want to talk to somebody
who's done this before.
I have no problems going on
to a bunch of websites trying to
find my counterparts
in other states.
I've connected
to folks in Iowa.
In fact, this weekend at
the Cascadia Art Conference,
I was able to connect with
some of our counterparts at Washington--
State of Washington
Department of Health.
And so yeah, definitely, the
data manager for my program
is right now at a
conference for national EMS
data managers. Like, there's--
there certainly is
support at a national
level. And we are
really trying to connect with
other R users in those places
because the data does
have national standards.
We've got a lot of R code that
works with those
data dictionaries that we're
using for doing things that
are both human and machine readable.
And we would love to share
some of that with other folks that
are R users. And so I'm--
package it. Thank
you, Ted. That's
my big thing that I'm
working on right now,
is building some internal packages. And
I need to learn how to
do better testing and all that.
So
anybody else learning
that stuff right now,
I'm game for study buddies.
- Awesome. When I see a
comment in the chat with, like,
a ton of replies on it,
I feel like that indicates
it's something good we should chat
about right now. ANDEY-NUNES
BREWSTER:
Yeah, sure.
- And so Eugene, I see you
had put a comment into the chat around
issues with working
with certain APIs.
I wondered if you wanted to
jump in here and just share
what you're experiencing
and see if we can maybe
figure something
out here as a group.
EUGENE: I guess what I
was bringing up is the challenge
of feeling alone working with R.
I am totally the one-man team,
3/4 stack ML engineer,
I'll call it. And
I could be full stack,
but we don't have a
good sort of like Posit
shiny server
enterprise solution where I can just
put my stuff up there. So
I'm sort of clunking through
with open source shiny server
and allowing one person at a time
to use my app for the one-use case.
But anyway, [INAUDIBLE]
HTTR is a very well
full-featured API
HTTP request package.
And I went through some issues
trying to figure out why I was
automatically
being dropped by--
I'm also in government. I'm
a government contractor.
So I'm going from the VA.
I'm pulling from Vista, which is
this monster, monster,
monster database.
And there's a few layers
of abstraction between it.
And we built--
or I should say some people
in our company built a wonderful
SOAP API standard that
allows me to do multiple
types of requests and [INAUDIBLE]
get
thrown in my arguments.
And there's an iteration.
You kind of have to do one
thing to open your connection, get the cookies.
You got to do another thing
to follow up and select your patient.
And then you got to select what
you want to do with that or how
you want to get
that patient's data.
And these things,
depending on the time of
day, it drops at night,
but it doesn't drop during
the day, or something [INAUDIBLE]
shoddy. So
I keep texting back and forth,
hey, this is what I'm getting.
What do you need to see to
help me help you debug why this
connection keeps dropping?
And it just turned into, well,
the people that are using
this are using Python,
they're doing it with
this request package.
I don't know what you're doing.
I don't know how it works.
I don't know what HTTR
is. And you must--
you have to change to a
fully-featured API request type of package
if I'm going to continue
supporting you, period. And like,
I've always had good
interactions with this person
until this just
really broke the--
I'm like, OK, fine. I'll
do it all myself, you know?
So it was that statement.
I don't know if there's the
right question for how to do
it, but I am building a little
R markdown report, right,
where I'm going to extract
every little frickin'
thing that HTTR can produce
from the request object that
comes back. And I will put
it out in PDF format and
hand it over and just say, please,
go figure out what to do. Because I
don't know what else to do
from a dialogue point of view.
I'm going to just
produce technical documentation [INAUDIBLE]
errors and send it right back to
them and say, hey, I need help.
- Feels like this is
communication,
collaboration piece that we've
talked about through some other
hangouts at one point
or another too. But
I'm curious if anybody has
experienced something similar
or has
maybe some ideas to share.
And Andey,
I think you were going to start
with sharing something too. ANDEY-NUNES
BREWSTER: No,
I was just going to
say I'm having some--
I'm feeling--
some of my feelings are being
reflected in the chat right now. So
I'll just say that.
Yeah,
I'm going to agree that
it sounds like there's a
communication piece there
layer to that, in addition
to the technical aspect.
If I had a question about
API stuff and why something isn't
working for me,
I would ask Ted,
or if couldn't Google it so.
I don't have a whole
lot of experience.
- Don't make me the authority.
- No, I won't, I won't,
I won't. I'm just--
I'm just saying what would I do
in this situation if I found myself
struggling with an API.
You know, I just--
I guess
we--
if I found a limit where
I'm finding that someone is running
out of ideas for helping
me work through a technical problem,
I guess there's--
you know, I don't--
pointing out all the things
that are wrong with something
someone's working on is
probably not going to help them
be motivated to help you
fix what you're trying to do
with the thing
they're working on.
So
I try to adjust
how I'm seeing it and say,
OK, we're on the same team
here.
And we just are seeing
this from a different-- you
know, it's the elephant.
I'm seeing the--
I'm seeing the trunk only.
And I'm trying to get to
this other part of it.
And the person doesn't see
what it is that I'm seeing.
And so maybe the process
of doing all that documentation,
you'll find something else
there that you didn't see
before. And then sharing that
process with this other person
might also
open the door. I don't know.
- My memory is being triggered
back to a hangout with Matt
Fraser when he was talking
about nonviolent communication in that book.
But
talking about how like, when
you get into this position,
like listen for needs
and express needs.
So starting with just
explaining I'm trying to do
this for the organization, like
I'm trying to help the company.
This is why I think
this is valuable.
Like, do you agree that
this is valuable? Like,
taking the technical
part of it. But like,
getting buy in first at what
you're trying to do is going to
be helpful. And then saying
like, in order to do that,
I have these needs that
aren't being met. Like,
how can we get to
that next step?
I'll share the recording here in
the chat in a second too.
Another--
we'll shift gears here.
But I figure because there
was so much conversation there on
that one, that would be
a good one to dive into.
If anybody had other thoughts
you wanted to share there,
feel free to raise your
hand too. I think Abigail,
you had shared a
few things there.
ABIGAIL: No, I'm
good. I don't--
for some reason, it
feels better to say,
you should use Python in
chat, when it doesn't [INAUDIBLE]
in chat. I don't know.
- OK. Well, we can keep
the conversation happening in chat too.
But Sanjay, I saw you had
asked a question about EMS
and the data formats.
You want to jump in here?
- Yeah. So
nationally in the US,
you've got a lot of data
integration obviously across
hospitals. And what I
heard you saying, Andey,
was that you've got vendors
and you got EMS systems implemented
separately for each hospital or
each state. Is that like that?
If it is separate,
then how do you integrate
the data across states?
- That's a really,
really great question. So
yes, each state implements
the national state data--
data standard in
the way that they
want to do it. So California,
a lot of larger states
that have a lot more
hospitals, trauma centers than
Oregon does, they
tell everybody, OK,
you're required
to do this data.
You're required to submit
this data to the state.
Here's the state repository.
Go out and get your
software and send it to us
because we're the
regulators, you know?
And so that's really left
up to those organizations.
They go and they
procure software.
Those vendors
set up
data pipelines
between the databases,
and
then it works, right? I
mean, that's the idea.
What ends up happening
is because of
requirements for
data validation,
which a lot of
this is built into
that software,
and requirements for
certain hospitals--
level 1's, level
2's, and level--
there's four levels of trauma
accreditation.
And those are based on the
levels of trauma care that can
be provided at those hospitals.
And so
everything but
your level 4 is--
on the national level,
is recommended that they
provide that data to not only
their state agencies but the
national database. And so those
software vendors
that are supporting--
that provide the
service to either
state agencies like our program
or the hospitals, they have
widgets within
there that provide--
that do that national data
validation and submissions for national data.
With the most recent version
of the EMS data, there is
now a data field that
is a universally unique
identifier for the record itself,
not the patient, but the record.
And that can now be linked
at the national level to the
trauma record. And so
there's an effort now
within the data standards
to be able to link these
at a national level.
That work is ongoing.
Oregon was, I think,
the seventh or ninth state
to adopt the new standard and
start to implement this
UUID, which means that our
interoperability between EMS
data and trauma data, you
know, like, we really have
to focus on that. When
the linkage doesn't work,
that UUID doesn't move between
the data systems. And you know--
and we're going to just have
for this first year or two some--
some data that isn't quite as
completely linked as we want it
to, but it's just a matter
of improving that as we go.
Oregon does provide
the service,
the software for all
of the hospitals.
They're allowed to use that
for free. They can just--
we provide
the technical support.
They can also go and get
their own implementation of an
integration between their
hospital electronic
health care records.
A couple of our
hospitals do that.
And then a couple
of the hospitals
have their own system and
export data to us.
So it's a lot of--
it's kind of all--
a lot of different ways
that it happens, yeah.
- Thank you. ANDEY-NUNES
BREWSTER: Yeah. RACHAEL
DEMPSEY: Thank
you very much.
I know that this hour
goes by so quickly.
But we were--
when we were talking
about Academy in the beginning,
I've loved to see all
the great feedback that you've shared,
Andey. And I was just
curious, how did you feel
Academy was different from other
training programs that you tried?
- Yeah, so the
collaboration piece was big.
Because we were
working together
on a weekly basis,
We were able to--
just form these relations--
these working relationships with one
another in a way that
probably wouldn't have happened
if we were just asynchronously
doing tutorials together.
And having the mentor
available for
answering questions,
that's
also--
it's not that there's someone
who's like, the teacher
providing this content, and we are
taking this content in
and doing a thing with it.
It was almost like having
a coach instead, right?
And so the group was able to
lean into places where we wanted to learn,
and maybe it was outside of
the content a little bit.
And they're just--
I haven't really experienced that
kind of flexibility with other
platforms.
- When you mentioned mentor,
I realized I missed a question
from Ben a bit earlier too.
Ben, do you want
to jump in here?
I think you asked about what
it meant have a defined mentor.
- Yeah, I'm sitting over here
shoving my face full of chips. Sorry.
- All right. [CHUCKLES]
- Yeah, but the mentor thing
is really interesting in that
it's a different role.
And so I'm curious how
influential it was to the
process. You mentioned coach,
but it really is a
different aspect to it.
And so I was curious how
you're carrying that on and if there
is something that you're
looking to in the future as you
develop the community,
if there is something you could
clearly define to the internal team
[? just ?]
if you might
fill that role with.
- Yeah.
So
I guess the coach aspect of it,
it just feels like there's
a slightly different power
dynamic than with a
instructor and student. And
it's like
there's a little more--
the--
I guess, as a learner,
I'm able to be a little
more self-directed
than like, I'm here to
take a class, I guess,
even though it really is
focused on here are your
learning goals and stuff.
As far as mentors,
we haven't really
had--
I feel like we've sort of--
rather than leaning on that one
mentor that we had during that
Academy session,
we've sort of branched out
and developed a network of mentors,
several of whom are just Posit
employees that are here to
support us, right?
And so--
so we've asked Jeremy Allen to
come and give our group a [INAUDIBLE]
demo, you know?
And I probably could have
put together a [INAUDIBLE]
demo, but like, Jeremy's
just really good. So
having someone come in and
kind of step up to that
has been really great.
In terms of how we're going
to support each other,
you know,
I think that that mentor is
really just a hat that we can
wear. And sometimes
I'm the mentor.
And sometimes I'm the mentee,
right? And just
trying to establish
the relationships where we can
take those hats on and off,
and I'm not required all
the time to answer someone's
questions, right? Like,
we're all here to get our
work done also, right?
So
I think one thing we might try
to do as the group is do like,
some computer lab
office hour study hour
kind of things, where
we can all show up and we
can work on our own things,
but then we can be there
to support each other and answer
questions. Like, that's been a
thing that I've thought would be
fun and amazing to do.
Be nice to figure out how to
do that in a hybrid setting so
that folks who are living in
other parts of the state and
working in different programs
throughout the state can still
participate and learn with us,
but haven't quite figured out all
the logistical details on that one.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Thank you.
- Yeah, and Jerry--
Jerry is awesome. I see
some of that in the chat.
Jeremy is awesome, yeah.
- One other Slido question I
saw that just came in was,
could you talk a bit more
about the team aspect of the?
Work is the analytics in the
agency centralized, or do
teams get put together
for specific projects?
- That's a really great
question. There's a little bit
of both. So we have a
data team in EMS. And
there is also
kind of like a health
policy and analytics section, division in
the agency,
where they really are
focused on just, like,
data and statistics
as it relates to
policy and programs.
And then there's
specific, like,
analytics and informatics
teams within programs. Like,
our acute and communicable
disease program has an
analytics team, or they've
got a data integrator.
They've got a data
visualization specialist. You
know, they've got
reporting specialists who
build some of these dashboards,
injury dashboards and things.
So it's kind of a
little bit of both.
It's really dependent on the
needs of the program and the
resources that the agency
has to kind of support
where that work is.
I think there's a couple of
programs that probably really need analysts.
And they're working on building
that capacity and stuff.
- Great. Thank you
so much, Andey. ANDEY-NUNES
BREWSTER: Yeah.
-
I feel like we're standing
on stage and people are chanting
for encore because
I see people asking,
can we have a bonus
hour right now?
So I know people have
to drop to other meetings here.
So I just want to say thank
you all so much for joining us
today. And thank you, Andey.
I know you probably have
to leave to another meeting,
but I can hang around for
a little bit longer if people
wanted to chat too.
- I also want to say thanks
for this opportunity. I get so
much from this group
whenever I'm here.
And even if I'm, like,
having to work on other
stuff and I'm just kind of
here to listen and learn, I
just get so much from this group.
And so it's just really been
awesome to be able to share
back. So thank you.
- I love that. Thank you
so much, Andey. It's--
I can't believe how long we've
been doing these now. And like,
just getting to actually know
people through the hangout is awesome. ANDEY-NUNES
BREWSTER: Yeah,
yeah. It's awesome.
- Well, have a great rest
of the day, everybody.
- Libby, your cat is amazing.
- OK, Libby, you need to talk
so I can see your cat right now.
- [CHUCKLES]
Oh, my gosh.
- I'm so sorry.
He has been, um-- RACHAEL
DEMPSEY: Aw.
- He just wants every
moment of my time.
And he's been jumping onto
my laptop and pressing keys and
changing things
on my screen. So--
- Oh, my god.
- Sorry he did a lot
of Zoom-bombing today.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Thank you.
I just pinned your video so that
I can only see you right now.
- Thank you, Andey. Bye, guys.
- Absolutely.
Thanks, everybody.
- Thanks, everyone. Have
a great rest of the day.
ANDEY-NUNES
BREWSTER: Take care.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: All
right. Bye, everybody.
- Bye.
- Luke, I see
you're still here.
Did you have other things
you want to chat about?
- No, I was just--
I guess my curiosity, if
Andey is still around, is
are there times where--
I know we have an issue with
our regulatory
body in [INAUDIBLE]
County. Like, they have
different accounting for their offload
time as opposed to ours
in the [INAUDIBLE].
So I wonder, like,
just how you guys have
kind of negotiated
when you have discrepancies
depending on who's reporting what.
- So, like, discrepancies
in just, like,
we're seeing certain records
coming over and we're not
seeing other records,
or like actual within
the record discrepancies? Like,
the record has this over here
and it's something else in this system?
- The idea is more, like,
when it comes to
patient offload times.
Maybe--
like, maybe
the EMS will start the--
will start their we arrived
here time at a different point
than we would in the EMR.
So I'm like, they're saying
the moment they, like,
pulled into the parking lot
is like when they started.
And maybe you were saying
it's like the moment they're entered
into the system or
something like that,
it's kind of how you
kind of back and forth.
Because they'll be like,
hey, you know, you're
15 or 20 minutes over
the ideal. And it's like, well,
not according to what we have.
- Yeah.
I wonder--
so one of the things
that we work on pretty
consistently is
having a demographics profile
from every vendor that's
participating in providing data
to the EMS system. And then
they're required to have
their system set up under
really tight specifications
for how each data element is
collected and then mapped to
the state registry. And we do
schema validation
to ensure that the
date that is shown in your
record is what comes over in
our record. And if
it's the same time,
it's actually the same time.
If it's
transport time, it's-- you
know, it's--
And so aside from working with
those vendors on really drilling into
what
information is being stored
where and how that's moving
from one system to another,
and just really getting
into those details,
like, we just have to do
that one vendor at a time.
Sometimes it's one
agency at a time, right?
And we're dealing with
over 200 agencies and
half a dozen different vendors
with each, a different instance
in a different agency. So
yeah, it's really just--
the data quality is just kind
of seems like a never ending
source of work.
- It's almost like emergencies
are a giant data mess.
- Yeah, yeah.
- --for a particular
reason, like,
maybe the fact that
they're emergencies.
But yeah,
there was actually one time I
think we figured out that the
discrepancy was because
they were not, like,
starting their route until
after their smoke break.
And this was one of the
private EMS companies that like drops
off patients here. And we're
like, so that's the issue.
But it's not the
issue all the time.
- Yeah,
yeah.
When the data is right but
you don't like what's in the data,
like, that's a different situation
than a mapping issue.
- The human element of the data.
It was making me think of the
Iceland, the City of
Reykjavik customer story.
- Mm.
- They were like,
why is this data for who's
entering the different pools across island--
Iceland
not mapping up? And it
was because when it got really
busy, they would just open up
the gates and let everybody out.
So it looked like people
who entered the pools were just
staying there forever. ANDEY-NUNES
BREWSTER:
Never left.
- They never left, yeah.
- [CHUCKLES]
- All right. Well, I'm
going to go eat lunch.
It was nice to see everybody.
Thank you so much, Andey.
And thanks all for
sticking around here, too.
- Yeah. Thanks, everyone.
LUKE: Take care, everybody.
- Take care. RACHAEL
DEMPSEY: Bye,
everybody.
- Bye.